نعود الى رستوف تحديد هذه المقاطعه التي
قال
انه دخلها بقواته نريد ان نفهم اكثر في
ايطاليا اهميه استراتيجيه التي اشرت اليها
في هذه المقاطعه كيف تتوزع بالاساس كونها
مركز قياده العمليات في اوكرانيا كيف كانت
تتوزع مراكز القوه بالنسبه لقوات فاجنر
وايضا القوات التابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
نعم لتوضيح الصوره مقاطعه هي محاذيه
لمنطقه دومباس تحديدا في مقاطاعتي لوغانس
ودونيس بدرجه الاولى هي مع لوغانس
بالمساحه الاكبر من المسافه الاكبر من
الحدود داخل مقاطعه دونيس كما نعلم توجد
معسكرات دونيسكو لوغانست توجد معسكرات
قوات فاقدر بعد انسحابها من الباك موت
هناك
توجد قياده
المنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه الروسيه حتى
قياده المنطقه العسكريه الجنوبيه
السوفيتيه كانت هناك منذ الحكم القيصري
منذ وصول القياسره الى القوقاز كانوا
يعتبرون هذه المنطقه هي القاعده العسكريه
الرئيسيه لديهم ولا فيها تواجد عسكري كبير
لمختلف انواع الاسلحه هذه المنطقه فيها
يمر نهر الدون الشهير الذي يصب في بحر
ازوف هذا البحر الذي اصبح بالعنف الروسي
مؤخرا جزءا من الاراضي الروسيه بعد سيطره
روسيا عليه ومنه تخرج الى البحر الاسود من
هذه المقاطعه في القرن التاسع عشر من هذا
المكان العفو نهايه القرن الثامن عشر
استطاعت روسيا السيطره على القرم ومن
البحر الاسود استطاعت احتلال او السيطره
على منطقه شمال القوقاز الاستراتيجيه هذه
المنطقه ايضا المقاطعه هي حدوديه مع منطقه
شمال القوقاز اقليم
والجمهوريات شمال قوقازيه السبعه الرئيسيه
وبالتالي هي من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه هي
مهمه اضافه الى انها خزان غذائي كبير واحد
اهم مناطق
المناجم المناجم الفحم في روسيا ومناطق
زراعيه مشهوره للغايه اضافه الى انها عقده
مواصلات وفيها تتجمع قوه عسكريه كبيره
روسيه الجيش الثاني والخمسين الروسي
وبالتالي هيا من الناحيه العسكريه
والامنيه والاستراتيجيه والاقتصاديه وكل
نوعيه مهمه ولذلك اختارت روسيا ان تكون
قياده العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
موجوده في هذه المنطقه كونها منطقه مجهزه
منذ الحقبه السوفييتيه من الناحيه
اللوجستيه من الناحيه العسكريه من
المطارات وكل الخدمات العسكريه ولوجيستيه
الاوكرانيه